une bouffée d'air aux portes de
villepreux après un an de travaux une
nouvelle pépinière de 8 ha vient d'être
aménagée près du nouveau quartier des
eaux du moulin de la ville à projets
attendus par les 10000 habitants de la
commune il faut voir d'où on part c'est
à dire que cette cet espace là n'était
pas valorisées c'était une friche où on
retrouvait d'ailleurs des carcasses de
voitures brûlées 1 c'était c'était ce
genre de choses qu'on retrouvait dans
cet endroit là et qui posait aussi son
lot de problèmes de sécurité
donc justement l'ambition de remettre un
espace vert de remettre de la
biodiversité en ville en aménageant en
aménageant cet espace c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui qui est très positif
pour la commune de villepreux dans cet
espace on retrouve des chemins pour
permettre de circuler des bancs et
également des pontons pour pouvoir
observer la plaine de versailles
au total la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines investi
près de 300000 euros
saint quentin en yvelines c'est 60% des
espaces non bâtis donc des espaces verts
agricole et forestier cet espace de 8 ha
donc s'ajoutent à ces 60% et nous avons
au niveau de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines investi pour pouvoir
ouvrir cette pépinière qui était tout
simplement une friche forestière la
nouvelle pépinière n'est pas encore
totalement terminée des arbres fruitiers
vont être plantés dans les prochaines
semaines un parcours pédagogique sera
également mise en place